can you hear the beat one local school
is taking music to the next level the
rock academy of the performance arts is
the music program at the delta academy
and that's where mary jane bellies is
now with the school's new music
production lab for students all right
let's hear it mary jane what's going on
over there
i know sherry we're just starting to
kind of play with a little beat right
now you know we're working on what we're
trying to make and make a song here i
have jay caballero he is the rock chief
officer here at the rock academy of
performing arts at the delta academy so
we're just kind of messing around here
and jay this is really cool what do you
have going on here right now so we have
a full digital audio workstation we have
our computer with ableton live
and then over here is called the ableton
push 2 it's a midi controller
used for like pad pushing making beats
and then down here we have an alesis
v49 which is used for of course
keyboards the keyboard controller then
we have our m audio audio digital audio
interface to connect everything together
and what's really cool is i mean the
students can actually also see what's
going on on the screen that you have
here so while we're making something
they can follow along too
and so i know we were kind of messing
around
looking at what we can make so should we
start making some music all right let's
just make this beat i'm going to press
the record and see how you do oh boy no
pressure right here we go
okay i can get on to this
i think i kind of messed up on the first
one
not bad there we go yeah it's kind of
getting there
okay
take it
[Music]
[Applause]
oh okay
we'll quantize it we'll make it line it
up we'll make it sound good as we kind
of mess with it earlier later on
it sounds a little bit better than what
i was anticipating so it's not too bad i
guess we're going to keep working on
this and then hopefully if i don't mess
up it'll actually sound better and we'll
actually make something that sounds good
there you go all right perfect so that i
mean that's more to stick around for and
we of course have the drum set going on
here and of course we'll talk to
students too
[Music]
there you go
there it is
i gotta get more practice
sounds a lot better too yeah we just
added a little bass in there and we got
your beat that's your b going on let me
get rid of the metronome
oh i can hear it yeah it sounds good i
guess we'll have to come back and figure
out what else uh we can do to kind of
fix it make it sound better at least on
my part there we go yeah so we'll be
back for that reporting live mary jane
valesa live local now